Okay, cornbread!
Okay, cornbread.
Whose recipe is this?
This is my grandmother's recipe.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
So this is a recipe, but we're gonna pretend
that there's just little pinches, and little this,
little bit of this and a little bit of that.
Pinches of what?
What goes in the bowl?
So here are our dry ingredients.
We got flour.
We got white cornmeal over there. I see it.
I'm sure there's a little pinch of salt.
I see salt.
And then we got a little pinch
of baking soda and baking powder.
Both.
Both, yes.
Interesting.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
I like it.
Okay, now in here, we got our little bit of buttermilk,
which I think about a cup, one egg, some oil,
and I think that's it that's in here.
So we're just gonna whisk that up.
Again, doesn't have to be perfect.
We just want that egg yolk to not be whole.
Okay, so we're gonna take this.
Uh-huh.
And we're going to very slowly while we whisk-
Pour it in just a little bit.
You good?
Yeah, this is good.
Okay.
Yeah, uh-huh.
So keep whisking while you do, while you pour.
Pour and whisk.
Mm-hmm.
Here, let me hold the bowl for you.
Oh, thank you.
You go, you go.
There you go.
(audience laughs)
Now give it a, there you go.
(audience applauds)
Get it, Drew.
There we go.
Yeah.
Yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes, yes.
How's that consistency?
That's perfect. That's perfect.
So we pour it in.
Now, this is where we use this 'cause we're gonna need it.
And we just give it a little pour-
Right.
Again.
Ooh, that looks good.
Right?
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
You did good.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
And it's so simple.
For sure.
And it's such a like,
I feel like a good, like not ancient
'cause we're not ancient, but-
We're gonna stick it
in the oven.
Where's the oven? Ooh.
Right here.
Isn't it nice?
There you go.
Okay, I'm gonna put mine next to yours.
Two little cornbreads
(audience applauds)
in a pod.
Two little cornbreads
in a nice little oven.
And then ideally...
It comes out like this.
This is so good to have.
Look at that.
(audience cheers)
And now we get to eat it.
Now we get to eat it.
Cheers.
To grandmas.
I'm so happy and honored to spend an afternoon with you.
Thank you so much-
Same.
Same, same, same.
For coming on this show.
(audience cheers)
(audience applauds)
It's a dream. It's a dream.
And give my best to your very kind, giving husband.
I will. I will.
Thank you for having me.
Catch Ryan in "The Endgame."
New episodes on NBC every Monday
at 10:00 p.m., 9:00 Central.
Episodes are also available the next day
on Peacock, Hulu, and the NBC App.
(upbeat pop music)